you know back when I was a kid in the
1900s Lego was just a brand of building
block playsets it hurt like a bitch when
you stepped on them these days as a
whole they still hurt a lot by the way
these days there's a whole Lego Empire
they got Legoland
you got Lego Star Wars this man's
horrifying skin textured Lego cosplay
[Applause]
now I know he doesn't office one why was
I given ID and no fingers Chernobyl
powers well we'll just weeks away from
the release of Lego Batman movie which
maybe they said I may have done a couple
voices in this movie maybe I did okay
very excited about it very excited about
this
it's very excited about Lego Batman also
uh shortly followed by Lego fences I
wasn't sure if you guys yeah i i i did
not get asked to be in this one today
windows banning in social media
launching Lego life a new Lego based
social network for children 13 and under
and probably me Chris Hardwick is an
Android and iOS F has a built in
anti-bullying measures chiefly than any
kid cool enough to be a bully is
probably not going to be on the Lego
social network so you'll be fine they're
comedians but this trend continues what
is the next social network targeted at
children under 13
Adam dish man east way off yeah boy very
good yeah
good baby tinder Garden yeah Anson Huber
it's like uber but for pubes yes so you
can go on it to have to have pubes
brought to you yeah yeah ok good I want
to clear it up yeah that's what I wanna
know Hubert eats is disgust